les pilotes d'un avion de la marine
américaine observe cet objet sphérique
qui passent à toute allure est ce l'un
des phénomènes que nous ne pouvons pas
expliquer
je n'ai pas d'explication sur ce qu'est
cet objet spécifiquement les autorités
américaines ont publié une vidéo d'un
tunnel long de 530 mètres utilisé pour
faire passer de la cocaïne entre tijuana
au mexique et san diego en californie
découvert vendredi ce tunnel creusé à 18
mètres de profondeur et est équipé de
rails de l'électricité et d'un système
de ventilation alors le congrès
américain décidé de lancer une audition
publique à ce sujet les pilotes éviter
de signaler les phénomènes aériens non
identifiés ou été moquée lorsqu il le
faisait ces phénomènes sont
inexplicables c'est vrai mais ils sont
réels ils doivent faire l'objet d'une
enquête très étonné de la lenteur de ce
deuxième de ceux de ce mandat depuis
depuis que monsieur mac ont été réélus
très étonné parce que je moi je pensais
en réalité que tout était bien préparée
en fait un candidat condamné pour avoir
frappé sa femme a été investi par votre
parti dans la foulée cette compte de
cette condamnation il avait quitté son
poste conseiller à l'elysée ce qu'il
peut rester candidat aujourd'hui oui
c'est très divisée de l'arrêt pendant
une seconde à cette question là le 4 mai
dernier une tesla avait foncé ou et sur
ces images dans un bâtiment de columbus
qui tombe dans l'ohio aux états unis le
conducteur qui avait perdu le contrôle
des freins et roulait alors à plus de
110 km à l'heure le pire on va vous
rassurer plus est très vite il avait
parlé d'une dispute en voiture ou qui
s'était mal passé et que sa compagne
était en train pas de leur séparation il
avait dit qu'elle avait essayé de lui
arracher ses lunettes et que donc il
avait porté un coup parce qu'il était en
train de conduire
aujourd'hui tu es t elle avait eu des
hématomes et douleurs à la mâchoire si
j'avais mais la conviction ou même le
soupçon qu'on ait affaire à quelqu'un
qui puisse être violent et coupable de
violences sur les femmes jamais non mais
j'aurais
investiture là il ya eu une affaire
complexe il n'a pas été condamné à
l'inégibilité nous dirons que pour un
gouvernement qui a fait de la lutte
contre les violences conjugales
sa priorité
ça paraît quand même un paradoxe assez
étrange ces propos de ces licences
guillon fait beaucoup réagir et puis ya
quelques minutes au qu'on apprenait le
retrait de la candidature de jérôme
peyrat lui-même le disait regardez avec
les derrières à stanislas guérini je
mesure que les propos que j'ai tenus ce
matin sur france info en réponse à une
question sur l'investiture ont pu porter
et blessés si vous avez une moto vous
n'échapperez pas aux contrôles
techniques la justice a tranché tous les
deux roues de plus de 125 centimètres
cubes devront s'y soumettre d'ici le
mois d'octobre le conseil d'état a donné
raison aux ong environnementales alors
qu emmanuel macron avait décidé de
renoncer à cette mesure et comme à avoir
mon avis ça juste pour nous pomper le
pognon en l'occurrence quelques dizaines
d'euros
chez nos voisins espagnols par exemple
c'est autour de 50 euros si jamais elle
était en butte à des critiques sexistes
à des moments difficiles misogyne nous
la soutiendrons je la veux dire entre
nous je pense que je peux parler au nom
des féministes des femmes parlementaires
féministes qui nous ne tolérerons pas
aujourd'hui ce qui a pu se passer dans
la différence avec edith cresson et à 30
ans ils sont déclarés persona non grata
en russie moscou annonce l'expulsion de
dizaines de diplomates européens dont 34
ans et doivent qu'est d'offres doivent
quitter le pays d'ici deux semaines
décision prise en représailles aux
sanctions similaires infligées à des
diplomates russes j'observe que déjà ce
matin madame castex l'appel est bien
madame j'ai vu ça passait dans la presse
madame madame castex c'est quand même
très limites en termes de sexisme on
pourrait dire castex 2 ça suffirait bien
droit qualifié la même chose donc ça
cognait l'ingénieur mythe longuement
applaudi par les représentants du
septième art présent dans la salle
le dirigeant en guerre a appelé de
cinéma ne pas être commuée en faisant
référence au film de charlie chaplin des
dictateurs laura bulletins au nom du
candidat ou de la candidate de la
nouvelle union populaire et communiquent
à je sais plus qu'à trouver un truc
pareil écologique et sociale là pour
deux heures à le dire